corruption hypocrisy greed what the
pandora papers expose about the super
rich is that it's not about whether
you're democrat or republican it's not
about whether you're black or white it's
not about whether you're from the north
or south what it's about is whether you
have 50 million dollars to put in an
offshore bank account and not pay taxes
on because it turns out we have 2.94
terabytes to prove what i could have
told you in about three seconds it's a
big club and you ain't in it
listen guys welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio you know the saying okay
we have been playing checkers while the
super rich have been playing offshore
tax evasion i'm not gonna go into all
the details of the pandora papers as you
guys probably know it's the third
installment from the uh the icij
international consortium bunch of
journalists working super hard to do a
ton of work that you should go read the
original source material of i'm just
gonna tell you the big high level
takeaways okay because i'm not here to
to read 2.94 terabytes for you okay i'm
i'm gonna be here a long time if i try
to do that instead what i'm gonna tell
you are the high level details and then
guys do your do your civic duty and go
read it or do what everyone else does
and don't but i think you should know
this basically the pandora papers is
just a continuation of what we've kind
of known for a while from these uh icij
guys as i said third installment panama
papers paradise papers maybe you've
heard of it a bunch of people lost their
jobs a journalist even got fired for
leaking this information it just exposed
the super rich did sort of what we knew
they were doing all along they aren't
paying taxes ladies and gentlemen that's
right left or right apparently when you
pass a certain threshold of wealth you
become
violently allergic to paying taxes
because it's not just the guys on the
right who are all about low taxes that
aren't paying it's everybody it's not
just the people who are uh for
corruption you know those pro-corruption
politicians that always come out there
and put their platform on pro-corruption
it's not just those guys that are hiding
their money illegally it's actually sort
of everybody
take for instance this man the czech
prime minister andrej babis
he promised to fight tax evasion and
increase transparency and surprise
surprise the man evaded taxes himself
apparently in 2009 he bought a french
estate through shell companies in tax
havens but that's okay because when in
france
buy an offshore friction state i don't
know this man's so rich that they're
even calling it a chateau at this point
dude you're not even in a mansion it's a
chateau of course he didn't disclose it
didn't appear on his taxes so uh
they asked him about it and he he
declined he declines to answer but it's
not just the czech prime minister who
sucks turns out everyone sort of dies
jordan's king abdullah apparently also
is the guy who promised to end
corruption that's the funniest thing a
politician could ever say they always
end up
surprise surprise corrupt
anyways apparently he while uh daddy usa
was pouring financial aid in
he was funneling it back out to a bunch
of property yeah well we were spending
money on him he was spending money on us
accumulating some a luxury hotel empire
to rival the hiltons i mean this man was
spending money like no tomorrow all the
while getting up on his pedestal and
preaching how people need to be stop
being corrupt i mean how do these people
honestly live i really do believe i mean
i know this is crazy this is tinfoil
this is not true but i believe that
politicians are a different breed of
human how can you stand up on a stage
and say hey we need to stop taxable we
need to stop corruption all the while
you got the guys going out and buying
these secret tax haven properties for
you it's completely insane and if you'd
like proof of that uh we also have the
kenyan president as well flexing the
weird lies that only politicians seem
uniquely capable of listen to what this
joker said it is time to get tough on
those who seek to use positions of power
for their own personal gain
this guy that this is this is the
anti-corruption hero of kenya now of
course uh this man who's against using
his personal uh position of power for
personal gain somehow is the richest man
in all of kenya which is uh kind of
hilarious you can see it right here he's
he's literally the bill gates over there
but yeah he's he's against corruption
and of course it turns out surprise
surprise the man is uh buying up
offshore islands offshore private uh
private private villas you know probably
some chateaus to get in there with it
it's like they can't help themselves
they're incapable when they get in
positions of power of just that you know
i put my hand in the cookie jar
but finally we get to see them unmasked
for what they are that's why these files
are so important and why these people
are absolutely crapping themselves right
now i mean look let me be honest with
you guys people like this people with
this much money they don't have a lot of
problems
just could if anyone who told you that
money doesn't solve any problems it's
not it's not true they're sitting there
on their little french chateau drinking
some wine but you know what does make
them actually worry the one thing that
does is this kind of stuff when when the
rest of the world gets to see them with
their pants down and gets to see once
and for all how corrupt these jokers are
left right front center and honestly
it's unbelievable to me that these
people expect the rest of us to pay our
fair share of taxes while these guys
with way more money can't even do it
even the even the politicians don't pay
their taxes the politicians who preach
at you of paying your fair share or say
that the super wealthy need to pay their
fair share while they own like 20
private islands i mean i don't want to
be too doomer about this but i really do
not believe that that many people in
this report are gonna go to jail maybe
that's a little cynical but it just
always seems like these guys always
slink out untouched all of a sudden you
know cause when you're rich is it really
a crime uh is it really a problem and
you know what i think is most telling
about these types of investigations
which i really do believe are deeply
important right but what i think is that
a lot of times
not much happens from these sure a few
people's heads might roll yeah like you
know people might lose their job and
stuff but very very rarely do any of
these people go to jail for what they've
done very rarely do we ever arrest
anybody why because suddenly when it's a
super rich person having to deal with
another super rich person and locking
them up all of a sudden that sounds
crazy it's crazy to think that we'd ever
um criminally punish any of these people
for what they've done be they're they're
sort of the legal crooks if you will but
meanwhile you know a poor person steals
from uh from a gas station everybody
loses their mind right that's that's
what we got to crack down on throw that
guy in jail for 2000 years but all of a
sudden you steal money from uh the
government you steal money that way this
this this offshore way you're rich dude
don't worry about it dude we got your
back it's so telling the super rich
protect the super rich that's just the
way of the world so i'm just gonna go
out and say it my takeaway from this
whole thing was that uh yes the super
rich are not paying their taxes surprise
surprise but even more than that i think
what this really exposes is that this
isn't about whether you voted red or
blue whether your boy is going to show
up on these tax havens it's about how
much money you got on your checkbook so
i don't know if people are ever going to
wake up and realize that uh the game is
rigged but it is because the same thing
we saw them doing in 2016 is the same
thing we find them doing a few years
later and it's the same thing we find
them doing today so if you think this is
gonna stop i don't know you might have
another thing coming but i do have to
give a huge congratulations to the
journalists who got this published this
is true journalist work i'm very proud
that we still have people who are this
willing to put their lives on the line
of releasing this stuff because it is
absolutely dangerous to leak this
sensitive of documents about this
powerful of people and the fact that a
team of journalists got together and
worked on this stuff i think is a true
testimony that we do still have some
hope i mean yes it is a little black
pill but the fact this stuff still gets
out there still does have some impact is
at least uh what warms my heart at night
so that's basically it i just want to do
a quick quick reaction of this because i
saw it go live i knew you guys would
wonder what the internet detective
thinks about corruption at this
magnitude and yeah it's it's kind of
weird it's kind of like a legal kind of
scamming
is what you ultimately find
we usually talk about illegal scamming
but there's very legal scamming going on
as well and you can look no further than
the pandora papers maybe we'll do a few
stories on it as more of them come out
but with that said thanks for watching i
will see you guys